there are few greater displays of U.S
military might its aircraft carriers are
still the best in the world and where
they move the world pays attention
[Applause]
the USS Nimitz is one of them an
enormous vessel a floating city of sorts
but its presence in this region is
designed to be noticed by one power in
particular China it's increasingly
assertive competitor so the total strike
group in general we have about 7 000
personnel
Lieutenant Ben bashong has served in the
U.S Navy for seven years he and his
colleagues know that tensions here are
high and their mission important keeping
the big picture kind of helping keep a
free and open indo-pacific and I would
just say we're always ready and we're
always training so if uh if we ever get
called we're ready to respond
and being ready has rarely felt more
pressing the Face-Off with China has
multiple fronts almost all are becoming
more fraught
yeah
indeed China sees this region as its
backyard its Navy's now the largest in
the world and it's making that felt
foreign
example a Chinese fighter flying
provocatively close it all means says
the Admiral commanding this carrier that
U.S presence here matters you know first
we're going to sail operate and fly
wherever international law allows and my
message to the PRC would be we're
Resolute in that
we are not going to be bullied we are
not going to be coerced and we are going
to stay here and fly and operate in
international Norms Steiner would say
that the US is trying to contain it what
do you say to that allegation yeah we do
not seek to contain China we do not seek
conflict with China
we seek to set International Norms again
that we all prosper from there is so
much about the rising tension with China
that is invisible and covert this is
designed to be the exact opposite the
message is very clear that any
escalation would come with grave
consequences there's a real sense here
that that message has never been more
needed
displays of Allegiance are also
important here China's conduct is
driving many Asian Nations closer to the
US and each other
this region is increasingly fractured
the stakes increasingly High Helen and
Smith Sky News in Busan South Korea